greatest yeah in the last few moments
published in the last minute in fact
it's been confirmed that south yorkshire
will move into the very high
alert level so alongside um greater
manchester
on friday of course and liverpool and
lancashire as well
there's a statement that's been
published by the mayor of the sheffield
city region dan
jarvis saying following extensive
discussions with ministers local council
leaders and i have agreed with the
government that south yorkshire will
move into tier three
very high alert level for coronavirus
that will come into force at one minute
past midnight on saturday and cover all
four local authority areas
barnsley doncaster rotherham um and
sheffield
nothing on there oh on the money front
the funding available will be 41 million
in total so 30 million for the region's
businesses so that's the same
as what um liverpool got that's the same
as what lancashire got
and then 11 million for local
authorities that's slightly less than
liverpool slightly less than lancashire
so
broadly in nine you might have expected
a little bit more given the population
there is slightly higher i think in that
south yorkshire region but of course
what this means for everyone living
there
firstly for the businesses for
hospitality it will mean that
um if they can't serve a substantial
meal they'll have to close so lots of
pubs
will have to close but it will mean for
people living there that they are not
able to socialize with people outside of
their household
in private gardens in pub beer gardens
they can still
go to public parks with other people as
long as they socially distance
and as long as they um stick to the rule
of six so that is
uh to recap again south yorkshire so the
areas of barnsley doncaster rotherham
and sheffield
from one minute past midnight uh this
coming saturday the 24th of october will
move
into very high dan jarvis putting
out a statement saying he called on the
government to offer a local lockdown
lifeline for our local authorities
and the new restrictions will be
introduced alongside resources which
mean we are better equipped
to control the virus and limit some of
the damage on jobs and businesses so
i think dan jarvis sounding warmer about
the deal that was done with the
government than we have heard from
other leaders most notably of course
andy burnham i think expect to hear
probably quite quickly the government
jumping on this
as an example of other labour leaders in
the north of england
coming to agreements with them and as
they see it working more constructively
than they believe leaders in greater
manchester have